Do you believe that all of those viewers would have watched Ethan's
thing live if Denims wasn't live? We need, as I said, we need
to do something about these people. I don't know what it is,
but there's something that needs to happen.
Ry, how many glasses of wine have you had tonight? Just between
like 8 and 12. I'll park it somewhere in there for me. It's not.
It's not. You just want to go off and explain something. You
do this all the time.
Yes. Yes. You No, do not talk about stuff there. No, I You're
out. I Good discussion. Good discussion. That's the classic Tyco
move. I'm sorry, bro. I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't do
it.
My mother of God. Jesus Christ. Why? Oh, sorry. This is the very
funny response from yesterday. It's funny, but it's like also
It's funny. It's one of those things. It's like the Darius play.
Okay. She's totally serious with this. She's totally serious
that she wants to buy more weed products, but it's also a joke.
Okay, Ethan. KKK Klein. Ethan KK Klene is going to sue me for
smoking too much weed. He is trying to take away my ability to
purchase my medically necessary marijuana products. We cannot
let this happen. Donate to my weed fund live on stream now. Let's
show that Kaka Klein's how to really goof and gaff. I believe
her her GoFundMe I believe also said she was using it to buy
weed if I'm not mistaken. She might have deleted her GoFundMe.
Hold on. One more clip. One more clip of Casey. But where does
it even talk about me? flamebait fixture. Casey Trron has been
streaming for over a decade. Not known for her intellectual acumen.
Casey Trron is not even conscious while streaming unlicensed
third party content. That's not true. Like that's not true. Like
I'm
what? I'm not conscious. During the subathon, Casey streamed
entire episodes of the television show Kitchen Nightmares while
passed out. Like, isn't that what everyone was doing?
I'm going to close this. I don't want to I don't want to find
Casey Trump funny. That's not healthy. That's not healthy for
me. Okay, tell you that. All right, moving on to
to the real one of the real ones. Okay, moving on to Asmin Gold.
All right, Asmin Gold.
Asmin Gold. As Zack Zack, he had some comments today. He's had
a couple comments today. I would like to see some of the opinions.
We'll see how it goes. I'm guessing it'll mostly be attacking
these people because that's mostly what he does. There's another
part of this where I think Techone reacted and said some, too.
We'll see. I'm going to I'm going to go through this. We'll see
what Asmin Gold has to say. Okay. I got a bunch of time stamps
for Asmin Gold and uh so yeah, that's where I'm at. And Denn
deleted her VOD on the H3 lawsuit. The thing is that uh about
that lawsuit, I'm going to just talk about that for a couple
of minutes, okay? Um they can cry, they can they can get mad,
they can act like they're uh you know uh like let me just tell
you this. The how can you say something bad about me when I'm
pro when I'm when I'm trying to fight against a genocide? That's
not going to work in a in a court of law.
And so they really should worry. They should be they should be
worried because the entire apparatus that supports them is completely
artificial.
It's totally artificial in it.
Did he say this uh when Ethan sued Noah Samson?
So the moment that you have people that actually, you know, give
a about reality, uh this immediately is going to fall apart.
And so don't you dare criticize.
Did Asmin Gold look at any of the complaints? Did he look at
that complaint that compares this on to the Grand Muy and goes,
"Here's a picture of the Grand Muy with Hitler and Himmler enduring
a genocide." Exactly. There end comes this you're about to get
genocided. Yeah, you're right. And uh that's it. She said she's
counter suing for doxing her, which I don't think he did. Um
I I don't think so. I think that I don't think you can sue for
that though. I don't think you would say you put my name in a
legal document, I'm going to sue you. I don't know if you can
do that. I'm pretty sure you can't do that. they do anything
about it, they try to get it shut down, it's just going to make
it worse. So, um, honestly, I feel like they're already, right?
And, um, also with people like that, um, once things like this
start happening, usually they keep happening. And so, like, I
feel like they're basically cooked no matter what. And, um, that's
summit, perfect time to ventilate. Denim's raised 15K for Ethan.
That's nice of her to do that. Uh, it really is. the United States
of Israel. Yeah. Surely will not help Israel. Well, I mean, as
I said, I'd be fine with them bombing the uh the nuclear sites.
I do I do want to Okay. Yeah, I know. He's uh he Guys, we need
we need to get out of these wars. He was totally a non-intervention,
right? Am I crazy? I feel like he's had every populist position.
He would have totally been behind. We can't be getting in these
wars, guys. We can't be getting in these wars. No, no. I'm totally
fine with like a small precise strike just on the nuclear sites,
guys. No, I'm totally fine with I'm totally fine with that. Yeah,
small precise strike just on the nuclear. Yeah, for sure. Wars.
Give me wars. Give me wars.
It's so annoying. He's a no boots on the ground guy now because
that's a huge differentiation.
Well, actually, it is a huge differentiation cuz you have to
get aggressive if an American dies. But like it's still crazy
to go and strike these other countries and spend all this money,
right? He would have been a no more funding Israel guy as well,
right? Asminold absolutely was a no more funding to Israel guy.
What happened to that? Oh no, we should totally shut our funding
to Ukraine and Israel at the same time. Yeah, we can't be spending
money over there. You got to spend it in America. You got to
spend it in America. Unless Trump says that we got to bomb these
nuclear sites for the safety of Israel. And then you're like,
"Yeah, of course we do. Of course we do."
Uh, it is a huge differentiation, but it's not one he can back
up because he supports Yeah, sorry. It is a huge differentiation.
Bombing nuclear sites is in everyone's interest. No, it is not.
No, it is not. Not given that his own intel agencies have said
they have no evidence that Iran's constructing a nuclear bomb
or working their way towards a nuclear bomb.
Given those facts and him just going, "You know what? Actually,
I just think Israel's got better intel than us. I trust Mr. Netanyahu
completely. It's okay. Mr. Netanyahu's been lying about this
since 1995 and that's a problem." Or maybe it's not. You know,
maybe Iran was weeks away in 1995 from a nuclear bomb. How do
you know? How do you know? Tulsi Gabbard walked that back. Yeah.
At the tip of a knife. Was at the tip of a blade. Jesus. At the
uh with a gun to her head. She walked it back. Right. What the
did they bomb then? They have nuclear sites there. They have
centrifuges, but you have to you have to like enrich uranium
to a different degree. And no international body said they were
making a weapon. The IAEA chairman came out and said, "No, no,
no. We have no evidence Iran's making a weapon. You can enrich
uranium for reactors. You can do this." What did I say? Yeah,
you can enrich uranium have it be for uh reactors.
Why 60% enrich though? It depends. But there's I believe there
is no That's true. True, but Iran was uncooperative with IAEA
inspections. How uncooperative? And I I'm just going to ask again
and again and again. Why did the director of national intelligence,
Tulsi Gabbard, come out and say, "Actually, there's no evidence
Iran's building a bomb." Why did she do that? Why did she come
out in front of Congress and do that? She didn't say that. Wait,
what did she say then? Wait, what? Hold on. Our most capable
strategic competitor
under the leadership of President Xiinping, the People's Republic
of China seek Wait, why the Hold on. What? No, this is a fake
thing. What the this one? March 25th. Can this play? Hello. That
Iran is not building a nuclear weapon. And Supreme Leader Kamani
has the IC continues to assess that Iran is not building a nuclear
weapon. And Supreme Leader Kamei has not authorized the nuclear
weapons program that he suspended in 2003.
The IC continues to monitor closely if Thrron decides, why did
this happen? Why did they say this? Why was this their position?
to reauthorize its nuclear weapons program. In the past year,
we've seen an erosion of a decadesl long taboo in Iran on discussing
nuclear weapons in public, likely emboldening nuclear weapons
advocates with We are worried they're doing a nuclear weapons
program covertly. That's a totally valid fear. That's a totally
valid fear. Where is the evidence of that? Where is the Where's
the evidence of any of this stuff? I'm saying my problem is exactly
this. Okay, we can't get that evidence, but we have a very long
history of Israel lying
repeatedly
about Iran having a nuclear weapon or being on the path or weeks
away from a nuclear weapon. Trump came out the other day and
said she lied and pushed out her out of his I know. Enriching
beyond the amount needed for reactors is evidence they want to
make weapons. Wait, is there no way is there nothing they would
use that for? Nothing for research, nothing at all. That's the
only only use for that level of enriched uranium is just bombs.
That's it. There's nothing else. So, literally any amount of
60% uranium is guaranteed that they're making a bomb. Okay. Given
these things, why did the IAEA chief come out and say there's
no evidence of them building a bomb? Why did Tulsi Gabbard come
out and say that there's no evidence of them building a bomb?
Given that, that sounds really good. Why did the national d the
director of national intelligence and the chairman of the IEA
both say no evidence they're building a weapon? Hold on. You
understand what you're telling me explicit? Holy [__]
There's some people who can't follow follow causality at all
in the chat right now because making a bomb and enriching uranium
are not the same thing. You just told me 60% enriching the 60%
is automatic. You are making a bomb. That is the only thing you
would do. That is evidence of making a bomb, idiots. So you're
telling me that Tulsi Gabra would see them enriching this 60%.
They would be making the 60% enriched uranium and Tulsi Gabber
would sit there and go that's not evidence they're doing they're
making a bomb at all. That's your opinion. Now they will use
the 60%. Well, honestly, evil evil Morty, I wouldn't be shocked.
It seems like having nukes is the only way any of these countries
get respect, right? You are not a sovereign nation without nuclear
weapons. That's just been proven out time and time and time again.
You are not a sovereign nation without nuclear weapons. Of course,
they all want nukes. If they don't have nukes, their sovereignty
is never respected. I realized Trump said she was wrong. If that's
what she's doing, evil Johnny Bravo, that serves nobody in the
in the entire planet. That serves nobody. I'm telling you, the
only way to guarantee your sovereignty is respected is by having
nuclear weapons. That is just true. It was true for Ukraine and
it's true now for Iran. If Ukraine hadn't given up their nuclear
weapons, they would have Crimea right now. Crimea would be a
part of Ukraine. How do you explain? Hold on. Why do you guys
think I'm telling you that your sovereignty will not be respected?
It cannot be respected. I'm telling you, you can only guarantee
your sovereignty with nuclear weapons. Okay. Yeah. Join waiting
room. Join waiting room. Tai, you're on the stream. What's up?
You are muted. You are muted. You are muted.
My bad. My bad. Uh hello. Hello. So, uh you say the only way
to guarantee your sovereignty is through possession of nuclear
weapons. Yes. There's 10 nuclear country, nine nuclear countries
right now. What about the other 190 that are sovereign? Which
which one of those countries would have any recourse if the US
decided they were going to invade them? Most of them. I mean,
do you think that Mongolia is gonna lose its sovereignty if the
US says we're going to put troops on the ground? Like, that's
not how this works. Mongolia is sovereign. I'm saying they they
literally have no ability to defend themselves at all. No ability.
And that the only countries who get to strongly defy US like
influence, I guess the only countries that get to do that strongly
are nuclear enabled countries or countries that are extremely
closely aligned with nuclear countries. I mean technically that's
true. Yeah, there are global alliances that maintain the global
order more or less. Well, I'm more thinking like North Korea
is a cutout here. North Korea is an interesting example. North
Korea did pursue nuclear weapons and achieve uh nuclear proliferation
for the reason of deterrence and it does work for them. However,
at the same time, South Korea is also very sovereign with no
nuclear weapons. Yes. But if again if uh if I'm telling you the
US decided to invade them, there is nothing people could do.
There's like nothing that country could do, right? That if if
the ever acting counter to US interest significantly like North
Korea does hypothetical, right? Or like like a lot of these countries
do, like it's it's literally the alliances between these countries
or nukes themselves that are keeping everything
like sort of maintaining a global order. That's that's my opinion.
There's no way to run Iran without nukes, right? Well, there
kind of is. Obviously, the the the actual domino that's gone
off here is Assad being overthrown, right? That's what's changed
everything.
It it is relevant, but it's not it's not that relevant. The real
domino that has has fallen uh is the recent IAEA report, which
happened right before Israel started bombing. I mean, clearly
there is a connection here. the IAEA, which is a very powerful
UN organization,
um it's probably the only one that actually
means much of anything internationally,
uh because nuclear proliferation and then when did the report
come out? I actually don't know the date. Can you give me the
date? Uh bombing started on the 15th. Report came out on the
13th, maybe. Okay. Um, had Israel already cleared out all anti-air
from Syria? Had they already done everything they were going
to do if they wanted to strike Iran before that report came out?
Answer is kind of, but answer is yes. They'd already also taken
out a ton of anti-air within Iran before that report came out.
No, not in Iran. No.
What? The first uh seed missions uh suppression of en enemy air
defenses in Iran was on um June 15th
or June 14th maybe. What? No. What are you talking dude? There
there have been they took out a whole bunch of radar station.
Yes, they struck Antier. I want to say back in Oh, was it February,
March? When did they when did they have the the trading of the
ballistic missiles and stuff? I remember them getting hit by
an F-35 back then and having no like basically stuff in Tran
got hit or something. They absolutely hit uh radar stations and
other anti-air stations before this like way before this.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. I'll give you that one. Yeah. There were
strikes in Iran, but it's not related to this mission. And you're
right that the air defenses in Syria uh and also Iraq to a degree
are degraded, but that's not that's not it's a convenient coincidence
for Israel that Assad fell
um and that Hezbollah was so easy to it's a really convenient
coincidence. I mean, do you think that Israel caused Assad to
fall in order to strike Iran? Um I think Israel absolutely wanted
Assad to fall and I think there were a bunch of interests that
were aligned in taking Assad down there. Okay. So, the United
States is what was Assad's What was Assad's strongest fighting
force ally in the region? Iran and Russia. Assad. Okay. There's
a fighting force that did a whole bunch of fighting for him during
the civil Syrian civil war. I'm thinking of them, you know. Uh,
can I do some beeps for you? Beep beep beep beep beep. Yeah.
He has
What happened to Hezbollah shortly before Assad was dead? Sorry,
before Assad was uh overthrown. He's not dead. living in Russia.
So you believe that guted? Yes, they were gutted and therefore
the Assad regime fell out
that
a massive issue after everything that Assad has been through
some pager
to Hezbollah in Lebanon was the thing that took him out. Some
some pager assassinations.
Uh, is there a single analyst on the planet of Earth who doesn't
say that Israel absolutely crippled Hezbollah's command structure?
Yeah, they did. But Hezbollah is not the Assad regime. Assad
has his own army. Or at least he did. Do you? No, that's actually
just totally Do you think Assad's actual standing army, his like
loyal allowite army, do you think that makes up a significant
portion of the fighting force in Syria? Or did do you think it
did?
Uh you realize Assad maintained power by having a bunch of coalitions
of different people, right? That he didn't have like actual people
who were loyal to him. He had he had militias that were that
were a little bit loyal to him, but realistically they were way
more they they were way more likely to flip on him and go with
any other Islamist group, right? He basically just very very
carefully played these militias off of each other and their loyalties
flipped at the same time Hezbollah was taken out and then he
had nothing. That's why it was out of nowhere he's overthrown
in like a week, days really. Okay. We would both agree that the
US has way more soft power uh and the CIA is way more powerful
or has more resources or more capacity to make things than Israel
and Yeah. Sorry, you need to say that again. I was sending a
message. Say that again. So, we would agree that the USA has
way more power than Israel does to affect change covertly um
via CIA and soft power. uh and backroom negotiations and things
like that. I don't know that their soft power in the Middle East
is stronger than Israel's. I would I would never make that bet.
I think you're insane if you think that.
That is that is wild. You're you're you're living in a different
reality. Israel is not that powerful of a country. Israel is
a dramatic overperformer for its size. Sorry, sorry. I'm talking
about um like like covert like their intelligence in that area,
their ability to affect or to to get other people to fight to
plan things. I think it's way different. I don't think the US,
by the way, I don't think the US has almost any soft power in
Iran, Iraq, like the countries that they've basically had like
negative relationships with, right? That's one of the reasons
they are constantly like uh fighting with these places. They
just have no influence there. It's very difficult to gain influence
there, right? uh Iraq, the country that we invaded,
uh completely overthrew and then put like 500 military bases
in. We have no ability to affect anything that's going on in
this country. Did you say soft power or are we using a different
term? Uh I mean it's covert operations like CIA or whatever.
I mean you you're claiming that Assad was brought down essentially
by MSAD actions. Uh no, they contributed. I think it was actually
mostly Turkey. I don't understand the Turkish um I don't understand
the the Turkish interest served there because I don't know the
region well enough. But I do believe it was mostly like Turkish
aligned groups who led that coalition that overthrew Assad. Turkey
I don't think played a significant role but they didn't play
no role. Oh maybe this is a better way to look at it from be
very vivid. I think uh the US could affect
I do not think that even though they can affect change I think
that Israel will affect change. Israel will go, they will violate
international norms. They will sacrifice a ton of their political
capital to affect change in that region. The US is not okay.
That's reasonable. That's that's a reasonable position and that's
probably largely accurate. Uh that Israel is certainly more um
willing to push their advantages than the US is. The US is more
likely to um be a bit more timid. But nonetheless, Israel did
not have the ability to overthrow the Assad regime because if
they did, you know, they would have done it 10 years ago, especially
during the during the war on ISIS, uh, when Assad was weak.
10 years ago, right? I mean, not really. Syria's always been
a with their relationship with Saudi Arabia significantly different
10 years ago. Yes or no?
It's better now, but not not not decisively different. No. Okay.
I think I think shoring up that relationship over the past maybe
15 years has made a huge difference in terms of how how okay
they feel like turning their attention elsewhere. Abraham Accords
mean nothing. Yeah. I don't know what to tell you. Um I'm I'm
basically my argument is that I do think they
the Abraham Accords. I can't remember. No, but Saudi Arabia is
the primary target of the Abraham Accords as in they're they're
making deals with all these other countries and Saudi Arabia's
always been the the I think basically financially it's more or
less done, right? They have trade deals now. They're never never
going to be quite something like the Abraham Accords probably,
at least not while
NBS's fathers the dutization with Saudi Arabia between Saudi
Arabia and Israel had been done essentially since MBS took power
because of course it would because Saudi Arabia and Iran have
been in a cold war from for forever and Israel is the natural
ally of Saudi Arabia against Iran. Like if they just put it on
a piece of paper, it's really not going to make much of a difference.
They're basically already allies. They just don't When did NBS
take over? Cuz I could have sworn it was less than 10 years ago.
Uh I think it was like 2015 or so. 2018
maybe. His father became king in 2015. Wait, is this that appears
to be what Wikipedia says. Then promoted to crown prince in 2017.
Muhammad succeeded his father as prime minister in 2022. Now
I know his dad was like insane, so he's probably running things
before that. But I don't know if it would have been before he
was crown prince. When did happen around that time? So 20 less
than 10 years ago. Okay. I I was pretty sure I had my understanding
of the region correct. Damn it. Yeah, the vision 2030 plan was
essentially NBS's I don't I don't know what that means. Direction.
Uh vision 2030. He formed in Yeah. Formed in January 201
proper nouns. Okay. 2016. Okay. So less than 10 years ago. Okay.
Yes. Technically that was 9 years ago. Okay. Okay. So normalizing
with with uh them and then obviously the Russian war in Ukraine
has put a strain on Russian military spending and manufacturing
in a way that's like never been seen before. So obviously between
Russian strain and not being able to support Assad and Hezbollah
being totally that is what caused it right like obviously the
region is completely different. Oh sorry and then the the Saudi
relation normal normalization not really worrying about them
in any way right so now they have the ability to act in a way
different way than they did before. So 10 years ago trying to
out trying to ou Assad 10 years ago is an entirely different
game than it is now. Fair enough. Okay. However, over the past
10 years, there have been many times that were easier than a
year ago to oust Assad or half a year ago. I'm not saying Israel
did it by themselves. I already said I I don't know why Turkey
did it, but Turkey was like the people they funded and and had
influence over like the the primary that was leading that coalition.
I believe the Syrians did it.
Okay. Everybody has influence in Syria. Syria. Okay. But it was
the Syrians that did it and probably the Syrians who did it had
all of their weapons, equipment, and intelligence from a country.
Would you say it's like totally insane to say the country also
did it? Generally, I' I'd be amendable to that, but Syria is
so complicated that Thank you. Okay. Um Okay. So to to get back
to the the the main topic here, yes, Israel is bombing Iran right
now because their strategic position happens to be really conveniently
really really good in order to do that because the Assad regime
fell uh because of Israel's actions in Lebanon, uh the um neutering
of Hezbollah, uh Israel is able to take action that they weren't
able to do before. However, none of this has anything to do with
Israel planning a strike. uh against Iranian nuclear facilities.
Um I mean obviously they did strike with a lot of force very
shortly after the uh none of that has anything to do with this
obviously I mean none of this happened because Israel was planning
and they were like pulling the strings behind the scenes. Um
you don't think that that Israel would contribute in any way
they could to Assad being overthrown causing chaos in that country
to allow them to gain a quarter%?
Yeah. Israel. Okay, Israel uses 100% of their influence uh to
shape the Middle East to their favor, but 100% of their influence
uh abroad like that just isn't isn't enough to completely overthrow
Assad without the Syrians having done that themselves.
No, but obviously they would have had contingency contingency
set up and obviously Israel probably more than any other country
in modern history will take advantage of a given moment when
they can. Yeah. as soon as they see, oh, Russia's not really
reinforcing Assad. Oh, actually, um, we just totally up Hezbollah,
that I I have no doubt that that that they could have easily
coordinated Hezbollah up with some of those militant groups to
say like, "Hey, you're going to have a window here with Hezblah's."
Yeah, Israel has is tactically probably the most impressive.
So, I'm sorry. The contention here, be very, is he's saying that
none of the things that happened in Syria have anything to do
with Israel wanting to strike Iran. And I don't believe that
to be the case. I believe that Israel was very very much would
have been very amenable and very up to the like in the no to
say, "Hey, uh, Assad probably can't defend himself right now."
Nudge, nudge, nudge. Hey, Assad's probably pretty right now.
Nudge, nudge, nudge. Because Assad falling and that country going
into chaos is absolutely critical to their ability to strike
Iran and these nuclear facilities. It's critical to within
terms of Israin
weeks of them having all of Syrian all Syrian air defenses like
destroyed or neutralized in some way. Within weeks of that, we
get a report and then strikes into Iran. All right, say that
again. Well, within weeks of them actually making it so they
have a corridor so they could strike Iran. We have an we have
an impetus for striking Iran.
within weeks. Assad fell like six months ago, right? Yeah. They've
slowly been grinding down all of the anti-air in that country,
right? I'm saying within within I'm sure 8 to 12 weeks, they
they suddenly have the ability to strike into that country.
Again, we watched a video from 5 months ago that said Assad falling
after Assad
Five months ago, somebody published a video. The Canadian report
guy posted a video showing exactly Oh, Assad just fell. Iran's
in checkmate now.
Like, Assad just fell. Iran is it's over. That was like the video
he made. Yes. Yeah, but you're you're reversing cause and effect
is what's going on here. I mean, uh I'm reversing cause and effect.
Yeah. Did Israel cause Russia to go to war in Ukraine and then
not be able to assist Assad leading to Assad's fall? I never
claimed that. No. Yeah, obviously not. Israel is taking advantage
of the tactical situation that they have. But clearly the strikes
have to do with the fact that Iran is once again like Israel
has struck Iran's nuclear program like six different major times.
This is just another time that they're doing this because Iran
happens to be very close to being able to produce a nuclear bomb.
Okay? And they use the tactics that are available to them. It
happens to be that Israel has been rolling a natural 20 uh every
week for about 12 months now. Uh but that doesn't mean that they
planned it all. Okay. I don't think they believe the Ukraine
Russia or sorry, I don't think they made Russia invade Ukraine.
I don't think they thought that far ahead. I do think that they
took advantage of the situation. I do think they helped orchestrate
Assad's fall. Absolutely.
And I think they did that explicitly to get at Iran. Yes. Um
it it was a tactically good decision. It benefited their position.
Um it's not clear to me that bombing Iran was uh on the Israeli
list of potential uh strike options as of 6 months ago. I don't
think that they were thinking about that at all. Um, Israel had
always wanted to bomb Iran. You don't think pretty much everybody
always wants to bomb Iran. That's why we bombed Iran.
Okay. I don't know what you're saying then that like that you
you think these strikes are only I you think these strikes are
only because of the report. I'm telling you, regardless of that
report, they've been saying for years and years, decades, Iran
has a nuclear Iran is on the way. Iran is right there. Iran is
two weeks away. Iran is two weeks away. that that report changed
0% as far as that goes. That report happened to come out and
they probably probably the only thing that changed for them.
Here's here's the only thing that changed that they could hand
this to Donald Trump and say this means that they are two weeks
away from having a nuke. And Donald Trump took it and went, "Well,
they look like they're two weeks away from having a nuke. You
should probably do something." That's the only difference here.
Yeah. Do you know what stucket was? I believe it was stores of
enriched uranium. Uh, no. No. Uh, so stuckset was a virus that
Oh, no. I don't care about stuckset. Please don't bring up stuckset.
Please don't bring up stuckset. It's not relevant to this. It's
relevant to their concern for Iranian nuclear. No, it's not.
It's not. You just want to go off and explain something. You
do this all the time. Stop. Yes. Yes. No. Do not talk about stuff.
No. I You're out. I Good discussion. Good discussion. That's
the classic Tyco move. I'm sorry, bro. I can't do it. I can't
do it. I can't do it. Hold on. I can't I will not. No. No. All
All Taiso wanted to do there was talk about a thing that he knows
in the background and he could just he just bloated on a topic.
Nope. Nope. Nope.
I'm not doing Suckset stuff. No. I I was willing to say Stuckset
is a virus they used to slow down Iran. Okay. And their progression
towards a nuclear uh a nuclear weapon. Yep. But I I am not going
to I'm sorry. He wanted to rant about it. I could tell. I could
tell. I'm so sorry. No, I know you. Everybody, everybody who's
been in Visu with Taika knows where that was going. I'm sorry.
I hate to be that guy, but I do have to actually watch the numbers.
Where were we? We're watching this guy. We're watching Asmin
Gold. I just wanted to watch him comment for two seconds. Ozel
is banned from the Discord. Latest Discord drama. Ozel is banned
from the Discord for 28 days for doing something. I don't know
what. Can I get an update from one of my moderators on why Ozel
was banned? Cuz he sent me some stuff and I have no idea. I'll
cover that update shortly. Okay, but we're going to keep watching.
Asmin Gold's comments on the H3 lawsuit. Okay. I I was okay with
the US doing that. Uh but I'm not okay with anything else, right?
I mean, I don't want to bomb the military. I don't want to bomb
uh Tran,
obviously. Uh you know, the problem is like why? Uh because the
nuclear bombs are bad. Same as always. Harassing Meis. Miatis
timed him out for like tagging him.
Meat's timed him out for tagging her and saying, "You should
hop on the stream." I don't think that was crazy. I don't think
that required a timeout.
But then apparently he got 28 days after and if they make nuclear
bombs, I think we could be in for I also think Malo was joking.
Here, we'll do this. We'll do this via poll. Okay, we'll do this
via poll really quickly. You guys can't do this. Malo should
probably get a day for this in any case. Okay, but I'm going
to I'm going to show you guys what Morau said and I'm going to
give you my thoughts on it really quickly. Okay, so Moral Moral
got 15-day timeout from the Discord. Okay, Iran just announced
that all US personnel are valid targets in the region. How is
this not escalating?
Um I So that's an they just got bombed. They just got bombed.
They literally got lulled into They got told, "Hey, let's negotiate."
Then they got bombed the second those negotiations were like
near their end, right? Then the country that they were negotiating
with directly, it was supposed to be the impartial third party,
bombed them.
I I'm sorry. They just got bombed. Okay, let's look at this moral
thing really quickly and then we can uh keep going with the Ethan
Klein stuff. Yeah, I want you I want you doc and but you don't
hear me flapping my lips about a So I think I don't know what
got said but it's to me it's clearly a joke now. You shouldn't
say that in a message. Okay, you shouldn't say that in a message
but I think it's clearly a joke. Who was the victim? It was but
you guys shouldn't care about that. Okay, I think you should
get a day timeout cuz you can't say this. But I think 15 days
is long.
This isn't Ozel. This is morale. By the way, this is morale.
It's not It's not Ozel. It's morale, man. Bunch of people saying
seven days. That's crazy.
Moral has VIP in the Discord already. Mau is a notable in the
Discord.
It's It's a thing to say. Yes, it's a thing to say.
Wait, I said a day. I say you get a I say you get a day for that
because it's a thing to say. I just think it's a joke. If I thought
you was serious at all, it would be Yeah, we go forever.
But I'm I'm just saying I think it's one day. I think it's one
day. Slap on the wrist. Do it again and actually you will get
15 or whatever the also don't send messages like this. You're
just risking your Discord account. Oh, the poll has come in.
People said it's between unban and 7 days. You know what? We're
going 72 hours. Actually, we'll bring it down to 72 hours is
what we'll do. Okay. 72 hours. 72 hours is what we're going to
do. I don't care if unban one. Guess what? This isn't a democracy.
I pull you guys to see where you're at, but I I will do 72 hours.
Okay? This drama community is to soy. You actually have to ban
people for stuff like that. If you don't if you can demonstrate
if people can demonstrate a pattern of you not banning people
for comments like this, you can actually lose your server. I'm
sorry. I care about my server way more than I care about any
individual chatter. You want to risk the server because you have
to be a you can leave. You can go away. Don't be a It's not hard.
Okay. All right. We're play. No, it's too big of a risk. It's
crazy. Okay. No, we're we're actually good with this. We We got
the first part. Okay.
I've got some timestamps for Asthma Gold stuff, so we'll just
go through. Looks like the pro posters at H3 Snark are roaching
out. Started seeing a lot of accounts starting to be deleted
after Ethan posted his lawsuit video. Oh, man. I mean, I would.
Also, I'm listening. I'm screaming.
I love it. So, let me see here. You should not use war on weapons
as examples because there those are always inevitable except
for chemical warfare that everyone became against.
Um, so I shouldn't use them as examples why. Uh, do do you have
a logical reason why or are you trying to make a moral difference?
Because I don't think that there is a moral difference. Saying
AI is bad now is ensuring powerful AI in the future will pull
up your logs and completely genocide you and your bloodline and
eraser for bad genes ideas to to prevent the AI from spreading.
Yeah, the Roku's basilisk. I know about that. Anyway, um started
seeing a bunch of accounts that are starting to be deleted after
Ethan posted his lawsuit video. They are roaching out hard. The
subreddit basically went on subreddit basically went on hiatus
4 months ago and now the accounts are starting to vanish from
it after being deleted. Even the moderator in Ethan's video with
the posted links deleted their account. I hope they know deleting
accounts won't protect them from the coming storm. From the coming
storm. I love it. Is Tai drunk? Is Tai okay? Jesus. I I I think
so. Like in my opinion, I think people this I've said this many
times. People on the internet have gotten way too comfortable.
They have gotten way too comfortable, way too uh, you know, pacified
and they think anything that they do on the internet is totally
okay and they're never going to have any consequences for it.
And now we're stuck. Tais, do you want to come on stream and
explain what Roko's basilisk is? I know you do. I know you do.
I know you do. Starting to see that change. Oh, did did Tiska
go talk to Queen on his stream? Did that happen? I I think about
watching that. I would love to watch Queen get annoyed by Tuska.
Did that happen? Someone tell me if that happened. Get rid of
anonymity.
They already did. Do you really think that you're anonymous on
the internet? If the FBI wants to find out what you're doing
on the internet, they're going to find out. No, they're I mean,
not if you take care of yourself. I tried, but he didn't take
the bait. Are you saying Quean ran, Taisa? You saying Kleman
ran away from you? The odds are that unless you're a very savvy
internet user. Like I'm talking like top 1% your ISP is going
to be able to figure it out. And most most VPNs give up your
data the moment that there's any sort of a Okay, cool. He knows.
He knows. He knows. Oh, what else do we have here? Um,
where's my asal time stamps? There they are. Denims, Hassan,
and Mudahar. Okay, a bit longer commentary here. H. What is this?
Because Ethan Klein's too much of a sue me cuz he knows. How's
the lawsuit going? Uh, nowhere because Ethan Klein's too much
of a sue me cuz he cuz he knows How's the lawsuit going? Uh,
nowhere because Ethan Klein's too. Is it like storming at Asmin
Gold's house while he does this? Am I hearing thunder? Sue me
cuz he knows he'll lose. I'm hearing like it sounds like it could
be like a chair rolling and I thought I thought it was me. So,
I thought it was where I lived and I'm like, "I thought it was
nice out." And then I I like took a headphone off and it seems
like I love these people though that are like, "Any day now,
any day now, he's going to sue. He's going to sue." The ISP is
always going to know. You can run a million VPNs and the ISP
is still going to know. You're just totally wrong, JNX. I'm I'm
almost positive you are completely wrong. And there is a way
to set things up to be encrypted going to your ISP so they can't
actually see where you're going on the internet. I'm almost positive
that that's the case. Um, I've I've uh I don't know the network
stack well enough to say exactly how you do it, but I'm pretty
sure that as long as your DNS is over HTT HTTPS that like you're
basically just serving out encrypted packets, there's no reason
your ISP if you're if a packet is encrypted going from your computer
at the at like the Oh, no. Cuz you're only encrypting the data.
There's like a way to go to like a certain tunnel. They might
know you're going to a VPN. Like they'll know. They could know
you're going through a VPN, but they won't know that like what
where you're going
Yeah. DNS over HTTPS and then a VPN. Yeah. Exactly.
If you're Yes. They they can know you're going to a VPN, but
they're not going to know your destination
and they won't have some tie of you to the VPN. You think Cloudflare
isn't going to give that data up? Um, we don't have to have your
DNS being there. But I I'm pretty confident like Cloudflare is
it not the case that Cloudflare wouldn't be able to tell you
um wouldn't be able to tell who the people are. I'm trying to
I can't think of this right now. I got to focus on I got to focus
on this. Sorry. I got to focus on Asmin Gold. I should not be
lose. I love these people though that are like any day now. Any
day now, he's going to sue. He's going to sue. Oh, he's watching
this stupid Ah, he's watching this stupid clip. this the these
clip chimps of denims not talking about this talking about um
like the defamation case or yeah like a defamation case against
her right she's saying she's saying sue me I didn't say anything
wrong right sue me I didn't say anything wrong she's like thinking
about the defamation case I'm pretty confident in all of these
clips how about that is amazing wow chat just a reminder by the
way just a reminder
after he paraded on the internet about how he was going to sue
me and he wanted to sue me guess what still no longer lawsuit.
Oh my god, he's so made. I'm actually pretty certain that he
actually his lawyer told him to stop going after me. Lawyer most
likely said, "Dude, like you like need to stop." Like, you actually
need to stop. Whatever. You think I'm an idiot. You think I'm
the dumbest person alive. That's fine. Go read the lawsuit. Maybe
if you don't want to respect me, you can go respect a judge and
a lawyer.
Oh my god.
I have never seen I I don't People think it's like it's like
oh this is so this is so related this is so like she's so owned
right now. I don't think that I've ever seen a person who just
constantly gets in the way of themselves this much. I mean that's
true in most cases. I just don't think this is evidence of it
in the same way. Like it's like you're you're just constantly
shooting yourself in the foot. But it doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter cuz it looks good and it gives the the people who hate
denims exactly what they want. So they can't help it. They they
will never be able to engage their critical thinking when looking
at something like this ever. They can't help it, right? It's
just too It fits It fits too well. It's so perfect. Constantly
sabotaging yourself. Like I No, this and it's honestly impressive.
It really is. It is impressive that it's this bad. This is what
happens when you think you're untouchable. Yeah. I think that's
exactly what it is. These people think that nothing is ever going
to happen to them. And because of that, that's the reason why
they're okay. They they think that they're going to get it's
easy to hate smug. That's true. Okay, guys. Uh, thank you so
much for watching on Twitch tonight. I'm going to go to kick
for the rest of the stream. All right. Wrong kick. Rest of the
stream. Kick only. kick.com/jok.
We'll see you guys there in a little bit. Uh, the rest of the
stream is going to be solo on kick. Well, it's technically on
X as well, but you're over on Twitch. Okay. We're going to be
over on Kick for the rest of the stream. Thank you guys for watching
on Twitch. We'll see you in a little bit over on kick. Bye-bye.
Byebye.
Okay.
Okay. We'll reset these timers.
Okay. All right. We're good to go. Get away with everything.
And um now they're trying to raise money. And uh Oh no, Ethan.
This is embarrassing. Oh no. Hassan put out a video about this.
The community is chocked. You can you can tell he didn't watch
the video. He can't sue you. He asked you to watch it. It was
never about you. He even says it was a trap for your orbiters.
Hassan said that I didn't say anything in his reaction.
Wait, Asmin Gold didn't say anything in his I don't know what
that means. I didn't say
Oh yeah, people saying I looked this up. I I don't believe Asmin
Gold's reaction was bad. I think unfortunately as much as Asmin
Gold doesn't give like material commentary very often, he's very
often speaking in like nothing statements that could be interpreted
in any possible way. As much as that's the case, he does pause
and comment. Okay, he does actually pause and give commentary
quite a bit. He doesn't just sleep through stuff. He just streams
a lot and he comments on like everything.
Like he does actually, but he does commentate.
I don't love the commentary, but he does commentate.
We're witnessing Gooner tactics never before seen. Pixie, I live
in Iran. Please sell me feet pics before I die.
Listen, since the lawsuit,
Destiny's Destiny's DMs have dried up, okay? He is going to any
extent he possibly can to get feet picss from people, okay? even
seeking them from his greatest enemies. Absolutely disgusting.
You hate to see it. And what do you
Bro got his friends smoked by lawyers.
Oh my god. That's kind of Some of this stuff is just amazing
to me to read. It really is because it's just it's so completely
delusional about this. Mudahar responds. Uh what is this here?
Mudar responds. Oh, of course. Yeah. Here we go. I love this,
bro. I love this. Of course, the
Yeah, exactly. Zezy. It's like I want to I want to get mad at
Asmin Gold because he reacts to so much, but he does do commentary.
He sits within that niche, right? I do think that if you have
a problem with React streamers and like not giving enough credit,
like he does give credit as well. He links the video and all
this, but I think if you have a problem with React streamers
in general being able to profit significantly off of other people's
works, he's probably one of the chief offenders. But I think
XQC is way easier to focus on.
XQC is one of the worst reactors. Genocide denying centrist only
comes on to side with Zionists.
I want to refer back to the comments that I've been making recently
about um work camps.
I think that we need to bring back um work camps and we need
to bring back mental asylums
and we need to put these people in the work camps at all. Uh
completely. Hassan said you didn't comment at all at the content
nuke. So you didn't get sued because Ethan loves you.
So I I didn't comment at all about the content nuke.
But like 50 people reacted to it and I'm only one person.
I I I don't even But that doesn't even make sense.
Yeah. I I I I don't even get it. Yeah. Three-hour reaction, by
the way. Well, I don't know. It was three hour. Why does he think
he wouldn't be put in the work camp or the mental asylum? Probably
he's rich. That's probably all it is. Threads pure brain rot.
Unlike you, I've donated your family's net worth to Palestinian
aid, and I've been against the IDF genocide since day one. My
only sin was not blowing violent terror organizations.
Again, being anti- genocide should be a given, and most people
are. They don't have to be deceitful liars like many of the extreme
left or the right actually are. We can uplift Palestinian people
from the horrors they face without co-signing violent regimes
from every angle that seek to oppress them on a daily basis.
Holy. Unlike you, I've donated your family's net worth to the
Palestinian to Palestinian aid and have been against the IDF
genocide since day one. My only sin was not blowing violent terror
organizations. No, I think your sin was like basically not spending
any time at all actually advocating for this position with your
platform. Like people don't know your private donations. People
can only base their opinions on you off of your content. The
only comment you've made on this up until very recently was,
"Oh, Asmin Gold didn't mean genociding people generally when
he said that," which he did and he admitted. Right. So it was
a weird defense of Asminold
uh against what Asminold's stated mental state was and then basically
attacking Hassan and Co. that those are the two things we have.
You defending the guy who made really unhinged genocidal statements
about Palestinians and then you attacking the only people defending
Palestinian who happen to also be terrorist supporters.
But based on those two facts, I'm sorry that's you kind of look
like you might be on the side of the IDF. You might be on the
side of the genociders. That's kind of how it is, man. What [__]
bro? Thank God. I I'm so glad that like people like this are
finally pushing back on it. Let me see if he said anything else
about this too. No, not not two M's. Let me see if I if I can
find Yeah, based absolutely based because people sued. Yeah.
Can someone remind me why Ethan Klein is suing Denims but not
XQC?
Who made that tweet? Can someone
sick? Oh, sick. It's sick Unchained. I didn't see that. Sorry.
I looked away and I didn't see who actually made it's sick. Unchained.
He's unchained. Okay. This is pretty rough with XQC react. Okay.
It's pretty rough. That's pretty rough. It's pretty rough. The
people being sued made a claim to actively infringe copyright
and deprive views/revenue from the original video without putting
in sufficient commentary. This is wrong. They did put in uh they
did put in sufficient commentary. Mudahar is one of the I've
been talking about that just takes Ethan's word for it and says,
"Yeah, Denims didn't add any commentary. Denim totally cherry
reacted, dude." And people will tell me Ethan's not like lying
blatantly with his video. That he's not blatantly trying to deceive
people into thinking Denim's cherry reacted to the content nuke
or didn't comment at all. 4 hours. Her commentary is 4 hours.
Two and a half hours to four hours. X, sorry, 1 hour 50 to four
hours. XQC 1 hour 50 to 2 hours 30. Brother, remind me why Ethan
Klein is suing Denims but not XQC. Uh, it's a good thing, Karate
Moses, that it's a strict liability crime and your intent to
create a market replacement has nothing to do with whether or
not you create a market replacement. That is not a good argument.
You trying to create a market replacement does not mean you've
effectively created a market replacement. It doesn't. Uh, I happen
to believe she did create one, but XQC also created one. In terms
of the pillar of creating a market replacement, XQC is the bigger
offender, the more obvious offender, the easier to convict offender
by far. By far
XQC goes H3H3 nukes. He puts himself in the thumbnail directly.
That is the only thing that's there. This Denim's react is not
even uploaded by Denims. It's crazy how much easier this case
on the merits would be against XQC. It's just that XQC is not
one of the people who did CPS. How can so many people be so That's
what I think.
Oh my god, he said something correct. How can so many people
be so This is We need guys, we need to get rid of democracy before
we have a big problem. We We've got We've got to We've got to
get rid of this. We've got to like I I'm seeing a big issue on
the on the We need to bring back I don't know kings, emperors,
uh manage democ we've got to do something about this before it
gets worse. Uh-huh. Yeah. This is a massive problem, guys. He
is joking. Now these people vote. We've got to Oh, uh the Anna
person is like now totally because Denim's openly stated her
intention was to prevent him from getting views and pirate his
content. It was malicious. Doesn't matter. It's a bit petty,
but when you consider the CPS stuff of it all, if another creator
is reacting to it in good faith and adding commentary, that's
different. So, again, not I need everybody to stop doing this.
As soon as somebody does this, I know they're stupid. I'm sorry.
You seem really dumb if you say Denim's provided no commentary.
You just seem very very dumb to me. Like, you you haven't investigated
this. You haven't looked into it whatsoever. They literally outline
via timestamps through the entire Denim's complaint how much
she spoke. They never once said she provided no commentary. They
said, "We thought her commentary was dumb, so we don't count
it." That's their argument. Your commentary was bad, so we don't
count it. In that case, Asminagold does actually pirate every
single thing. He does actually steal. He does actually fail to
transform every single piece of content he looks at, if that's
the bar. And we've the thing is we've got to find a way to stop
them from voting because the people being sued made a claim to
actively infringe on copyright and deprive views and revenue
from the original video without putting in sufficient commentary.
This is blatantly obvious if you put in a minute of actual re
there's no way Mudahar said a minute of actual research. Are
you serious? He put in a minute of actual research without putting
in sufficient commentary. He he did both of these at the same
time. He did both of these things at the same time to a tweet
where he can see the 4hour time stamp versus the 2 hour 30 time
stamp. The point here of six tweet is Denims did do substantial
commentary. XQC did not do substantial commentary. Now I understand
that extra run uh extra runtime is not necessarily better or
more uh more uh
complete commentary. It's not necessarily more commentary or
more transformative because you've taken a long time to go through
it. But she does comment a lot. She pulls examples to try to
disprove what Ethan's saying. She is critiquing the piece of
media. She is critiquing. Yes. All you have to do is read what
it says. It's literally that simple. I I don't know how this
happens and how these people are just so absolutely um what's
the first line of the Denims lawsuit? We need to prevent lazy
reacts. That's the first line of the lawsuit. Uh we're doing
this to prevent lazy reacts.
That's not what Denims did. Delusional. I've acclaimed our videos
to deprive uh H Bhane. I don't know. I don't know if that's actually
a real argument. I don't know if you can make that argument.
You might be able to because I believe there's been I think second
was telling me that one of the cases he looked at basically creating
like more effective packaging for a thing was considered transformative
enough for that thing to pass like fair use. So like basically
by putting a different packaging on something, you you're actually
like fairly using it. I I can't remember what that was precisely
at the actual viewer content. It's amazing if I can read this.
Oh my god, bro. Go back to buying slot Nintendo.
If you're going to talk politics, don't be a and actually talk
politics. Yeah, he
he literally showed the So, Jog, do you disagree the characterization
that Denims just picked one of the two sides printed in the video
and did presented in the video and did not create original thought?
I don't know if the words mean what I mean. Denim just picked
one of the two sides. It doesn't matter if she just picked one
of the two sides. She did present like arguments, right? She
is trying to argue. She's presenting like an opinion. You can't
say just because her her opinions are like handed to her by somebody
else that they're not opinions and it's not transformative. How
do how is it possible that so Hassan's audience would have watched
it on Ethan's channel if left with no alternative? I don't know
that that's true. Kogan style. I don't know if that's true for
all of these people. If they had to give money to Ethan Klein
to watch these things, I don't know that they would all watch
it. Many people can just be just blatant liars. It's unbelievable.
How are these How are these real? I watched your video on this
subject this morning. My only question is would could a defense
on enttrapment be made?
Entrament. The problem there is like I think I again I think
it comes down to what the actual fact of the matter is as far
as enttrapment would go. And like the uh
yeah, it's again strict liability. I I think it's like it could
be bad in terms of it may give like the enttrapment thing would
be more about creating an environment where where you might be
able to argue an implicit license like an implied license, right?
I think that's way closer. I think I think that's more what it
is. It's not necessarily
it is not that you could entrap somebody to copyright infringe.
It's that you've created an environment where they have reacted
to your stuff. You've reacted to their stuff. They react to you.
You react to them. They react to you. You react to them. Back
and forth and back and forth and back and forth. And then you
go, "Oh, well, they're really they're really invested in this.
I bet you if I copyrighted a piece of content, I bet you they'd
react to it again. I bet you they'd do it again." Right now you
have to put into this. So now he wants to sue them because they
said they wanted to do it to hurt him. Right? That's They shouldn't
have done that. That's really bad. They're total moral repbates.
We've known that like Casey Tron's a moral repbate for a while.
Denim's obviously a Frogen. Yes. But um but I don't know. I don't
know that them being like malicious actually makes it okay to
create that environment and then try to um and then try to capitalize
on it by suing them. I don't know. I don't know. Didn't somebody
comment on this? Didn't ironically you're arguing there was implied
consent to consume his content. I It's not ironic. It's not ironic
at all. That's a legal argument that many people have made in
terms of fair use that I had an implied license or sorry in copyright
court that I had implied license. You can make that argument.
The only time it would be to make that argument is if you're
being sued under a statute that explicitly says intent doesn't
matter. Like somebody we all know, like a [__] like
that. Okay, hold on. What is this tweet? He then posts a clip
of legal mindset laughing at Hassan and Co thinking entrapment
is applicable to the Caseyron. This is not criminal. Yeah, you
can trap somebody into a civil thing apparently. Oh, we should
watch this. I Hold on. Should we watch it before we finish the
Asminold stuff? I do want to actually go through and watch the
legal mindset video. Hold on. Where's Where's our boy? Legal
mindset.
Uh, what? Why did that just go to my dashboard? What the what
the legal mindset? I want to watch his 8 minute fast fact video.
Uh, not his stream. Fastf facts. Fastf facts. Give me his fastf
facts video. Fastf facts.
Fast facts. Legal mindset. Lady boy mindset. Lolly mindset. I
with Andrew Esquire. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Ethan Klein has
sprung a copyright trap against some react. Most of these blockubers
are I know, but I'll still watch it. Action channels which reacted
to his content nuke of Hassan, but will it work? We're going
to get into it today. Of course, I'm Andrew Esquire, American
attorney living in Asia. This is the legal mindset where we teach
you get this guy on the stream. I might be able to get him on
the stream at some point. I talked to him a little bit in DMs
on Twitter, I think. I don't know. We'll see. Probably be on
some different topics. Be your own judge. So, let's get right
into it. This is a really fascinating issue because it really
brings up issue of copyright at large and how it's enforced on
the internet on all platforms. This can have massive ramifications
across really every single major streaming platform whether YouTube,
Twitch, etc. All of them have so many reaction channels and this
has a potential to affect really all of them. Why would a smart
attorney be living in Asia anyway? Uh because he's a fetishist
probably. Despite the fact it seems like it's targeted at just
three people. So what's going on? Well, Ethan Klein recorded
a content nuke of Hassan in an ongoing feud between the two.
Now today we're not going to get into, you know, the personal
dynamics and all the subjective stuff of Ethan versus Hassan,
etc. We're going to focus on the objective law and the bigger
broader issues at stake. So that content nuke many I love the
law and I love objectivity. This video is for me. People who
did not like Ethan sorry I'm being I
went and reacted to his video and some people did add very substantial
very lengthy commentary to that but others were it appears simply
rereaming
that content. How does everybody read this complaint or watch
Ethan's video and believe that this could apply to denims without
checking at all without like honestly the idea that you could
read the complaint on Denims and not understand this is kind
of insane on its own, right? That you could read the complaint
where they say here's a timestamped table of all the times she
speaks and you don't understand that she gave substantial commentary
in order to prevent the views from coming to Ethan Klein. So,
in response to that, it turns out that Ethan Klein actually registered
his copyright of that content nuke and is now suing three creators.
And this is a really, really big deal because these reaction
channels, while they're small in comparison, right, while they're
respond to Ethan and other very large channels, uh, people told
him that Denims did proper commentary in the live stream, but
he said that won't save her. It won't save her. Basically, almost
certainly Karate Moses, almost certainly most React content is
actually in violation of copyright. Almost certainly. We're going
to get into some weird bulanized state where like you can only
react to people who like agree with your politics where like
if it's it's literally why the current state is good. Well, it'll
show us why. Okay? Because we're going to get into a state where
basically reacting to people watching their commentary, you're
going to have people like DMCAU try to take you to court over
it, right? I think that's what it's going to be. It's going to
be used to just chill free speech, chill uh criticism. Now, that's
going to be what it is. It's so stupid. It can set a precedent
which can echo across other creators and all all platforms really.
And what's at stake is the definition of what is transformative,
what you can do to react to a video. Now, there have been several
cases which have gone different ways. There have been cases where
people have just re-uploaded videos and that hasn't worked. But
there also are different cases where people have taken a video
and clipped it and added a different title, a different thumbnail,
and courts have said, "Hey, that's okay." What are they looking
at? What are they looking at? Is is it a substitute? Are you
substituting one for the other? And that's the real core of the
question here today. Are these reaction channels? Are these people
reacting to Ethan? Are these substitutes for Ethan's content?
And beyond that, it appears that there may even be malice on
the part of many of these parties who literally intended it to
be for to be a substitute to Ethan's content to his. So here's
the thing about creating a market substitute.
Is that content made in a way that is neutral in a way that like
people who are on Hassan's side would actually like digesting,
right? Oh, cuz I really do think there's an argument for like
people, especially with political topics, are not looking for
somebody who's telling them how they're wrong. They're looking
for somebody who's telling them like they're correct. Your your
opinions are correct. So, would those people have really wanted
to watch it with like just their side getting totally dragged
or is the way that they decide to consume it waiting for somebody
on their side to explain why that video is wrong? Right. I I
think there's there are real arguments there. I just I can't
see them going very well personally, but I'm not we just have
to see it, right? We have to see how it plays out. And that is
a top issue. Now, Ethan did say one thing which I need to clear
up because there needs to be some baseline about what copyright
is and what's going on with copyright. So, let's like, okay,
I I think this won't work because I don't know how you prove
it. The issue would be if you were to take this out of the realm
of
of streamers and you move it into the realm of like movies. If
you were to take like a Star War a Star Wars fan site that ripped
and reproduc and reposted or or you know did a watch party of
like the new Star Trek movie. Okay, Star Wars fans watching the
new Star Trek movie. Let's say uh saying hey these people they
hate Star Trek. They would never watch it. It's like us ripping
on this movie. It's like a bad movie watch. We're we're like
talking [__] We would never have watched it on its
own. Is that Can you really say that's transformative? Is that
really a way to get around it? I don't know. And are you creating
a replacement? Like there maybe there's some uh I can't imagine
that working. And because I can't imagine that working, I can't
imagine the streamer version working or like a boomer judge being
able to sign off on the uh the streamer version. Let's listen
to Ethan here talking about him registering that copyright. And
I'll explain things as we go. One thing about copyright you should
know is that you got to register it before you publish to be
eligible for statutory damages and attorneys fees, which is XQC
argued that chat experience enough is transformative. I think
that is an argument. I do think that is an argument. I think
there's a real argument there. I don't know. Yeah, I don't know.
We'll see. The main biting force of a copyright infringement
lawsuit. Well, I'm happy to tell you guys now. I, Ethan Klein,
have registered a content nuke with the United States Library
of Congress. Some of you guys out there sweating. One thing about
copyright, that's a really interesting fact. So, one thing to
clear up is you do have copyright protection as soon as you create
a work. So, if you create a piece of art, a book, etc., you have
copyright protection. However, what Ethan is talking about is
a requisite to suing. So even if you have already you already
created something, you have protections that exist automatically
as a requirement to sue and especially to get those damages.
Yes, you're going to need to go through the registration process.
So
um no, to get so to get statutory damages. It's just for statutory
damages.
You could sue you could sue regularly. The laws are all the same.
The damages they would award to you are all the same. But if
you register it, you can sue for for statutory damages. And I
I believe this is mostly utilized by or was mostly utilized during
the early file sharing stuff. I think this this idea that like
I want statutory damages if there's maliciousness because basically
you most of the time what it used to be was you'd have damages
enough if somebody built up a large enough enterprise you could
gain damages from them. But then the peer-to-peer stuff changed
things so that you have people who are like re-uploading songs
but they don't actually like make money. They're like kind of
just re-sharing these things and you want to criminalize that
or you want to make that dangerous for people. I think that's
how this came about. Am I crazy? That's some of the case law
I looked at for sure. So that's what he's speaking about here
in terms of those damages. So while many people say that's not
right, copyright's automatic. Well, no, what he's saying is correct,
but he doesn't fill in the blanks with the fact that yeah, no,
you indeed have copyright as soon as you create something. And
mind you, there are exceptions to that. For example, live broadcast.
Live broadcast. I'm going to use AI to figure this out. Um, when
were
damages for registered
copyrighted
works
for infringement
infringement
on registered copyrighted works established in the in US federal
law are an exception to the copyright rule for registration.
So while there are holes in that and there are some exceptions,
uh, Ethan is generally right here. And what he did was he registered
this copyright beforehand in order to later enforce that because
he knew people were going to react to that. Oh, I was totally
wrong. 1976.
is when that came to be. So I lied to you. Now some people have
said this is a trap. Call the admiral actar. It's a trap. But
really the law doesn't care whether or not you set it up that
way because Frank trusting AI. I do trust AI in this case that
it's a part of the 1976 copyright act. in the eyes of law. I
don't know why. Why do you guys think trusting AI is bad? Uh,
can you show me
a source for the statutory
damages
for willful
infringement
being introduced as a part of the main bill in
It's really not that bad. Wasn't this guy proven to be a totally
worthless? No. Okay. No. No. No. It is a part of the 1976. Planning
to enforce your copyright. If you knew somebody was going to
steal something from you and you took it, it'll just make stuff
up. Yeah, that's why, dude, you literally can just say, "Hey,
can you like tell me can you cite me that?" You literally just
ask it to sight it and then you read the citation. It's so not
difficult. It's so so not difficult. A measure to protect yourself.
That's not a trap. That's like calling a house alarm a trap against
burglars because it calls the police automatically. That's not
really what happens here. And that's not really a defense. And
frankly, I think one of the biggest issues here is that all uh
see he's not I I would just like to hear his argument against
it's like what if you made it so people could actually burgle
your house and then you just decided that you didn't like somebody
who you had allowed who you'd set this up with who like breaks
into your house at night. You know, a bunch of people break into
your house at night, but then you decided to sue this one person
after you've created like a culture of people breaking into your
house at night. All of these channels were making it very very
clear that you should watch them instead of Ethan. Now the one
thing to be really concerned about and the the problem I see
coming out of this if Ethan does prevail is the chilling effect
that is the other channels that are going to be scared to do
reaction content because of this and beyond that platforms platforms
may aggressively enforce against reaction channels. So there
could be a massive movement a massive massive wipe of reaction
channels at large and this could be really dangerous because
it has the potential of a slippery slope of going too far. At
what point is it transformative? Now his argument is well if
you get up out of your chair for you know half of the stream
or significant portion of the stream that's not transformative.
Well how much do you have to comment on? Is it 10%? Is it 20%?
Is it 50 oh this is unfortunately he doesn't so is it 75%. That's
he like kind of doesn't know. Dude everybody just takes Ethan's
word for it on this. It's so weird that like people just read
it and they're like yeah I'll take his word for it. Really a
hard thing to judge and a judge in these cases is doing it case
by case point by point. Now, I think Ethan does have a chance
to prevail against these three creators, particularly because
of the egregious things they said. Now, we're not going to get
into this on the fast facts version. This is, of course, the
quick and dirty version of my uh analysis, but if you watch my
live on this, we're going to watch the entire video, the entire
20 minutes, which goes into what these creators did and how they
went through their analysis. But safe to say that most of them
did not do deep, lengthy, in-depth analysis. They mostly just
sat there, watched, made a couple noises, grunts. Some of them
were appearing to take bong hits during you. Oh, you're not actually
he didn't actually check it bring this or you know smoking something
during it. Uh while that might in some be quote unquote transforming
it in a way whether a judge thinks that's changing it to something
different that is not a substitute is the real question. And
I think here Ethan has a very very strong case to say yep that's
not a uh that's not a major transformation. You're not adding
anything educational, entertaining, etc. It's really just you
sitting there and trying to filter off you're owned or whatever.
I'll just like what why why am I watching this? Why would you
just link me some random clip? But what do you guys think?
Do you think this is something that might go Ethan's way? Do
you think it's something that might go the way of the reaction
channels? And do you guys enjoy reaction channels? Because I
know some people think that their content leeches. Some people
think that the reaction channels are useless. I don't know what
you guys think. Let me know in the comments below and I will
c uh what does it say or whatever? I'll just like basically manage
it for my business going forward. Four months ago, you're linking
me a 4mon old clip of Queenman. Riy, how many glasses of wine
have you had tonight? Just between like 8 and 12. I'll park it
somewhere in there for me. You showed up to throw a random clip
of Queenman that's four months old in my chat. Trust. I don't
trust. One thing I hate is that the I is the idea is this idea
that a video will be judged all fair use or not fair use. You
can 100% say some sections are fair use and some are not. You
see art in art all the time where sections of work are judged
as fair or not and only those sections are penalized.
Oh, interesting. Yeah. But I think I think the issue here top
Bronson is that um you could do like pre-work to make sure that
you're not falling like a lot of it is not falling outside of
fairness, right? I believe in Riyle. Yeah, I haven't covered
that legal mindset video because the guy I I take that guy's
totally worthless
after a [__] I'm sorry. You you can't you can't be
a lawyer YouTuber make these super strong statements get proven
totally end up totally wrong. So, I'd have to see what his statements
were, right? You just you just gave me I just want to make it
clear that you you think the guy sucks cuz Queen said he sucks,
right? You haven't seen like the bedrock opinion. This probably
not good. It's probably like quite not good to not I like I haven't
seen it. I can't say anything.
I feel like and other people people do this. This is not good.
You should be able to say what actually happened there. I don't
I don't see it happening. And then expect to be trusted again.
And if you do trust people like that, you're a complete mark.
You're an utter mark. There's AI, but not Queman. I trust the
thing that will show me the article. Hold on. I I trust the thing
that shows me the article. I trust Queen whenever he shows me
Queen always constantly shows me sources for things. He constantly
is willing to look for those things. I'm saying right now in
this video, I don't see this as like this guy necessarily being
bad. Right.
Come on. Texas Law Review. Like it's literally giving me this
saying, hey, mountainous awards for molehill infringement, curbing
excessive awards of copyright statutory damages in the digital
age. So this is basically arguing I think that basically the
statutory damages are made for something else but these statutory
damages are being sought against like an individual.
What you asking me? Oh no, I'm not asking you anything. I literally
was just pointing out that like people are like you shouldn't
listen to legal mindset and I was like why? And then they sent
me a video of you saying legal mindset, but the Rakita thing.
And I'm like, well, that doesn't give me anything. I like I don't
I need to see actual information. A streamer telling me this.
This is like all a part of the problems we've been having for
months now. Remember what Legal Mindset said about the uh Yeah,
I wouldn't even like you know, for the backlash statement, you
know, I probably I don't even I don't even know what information
I was basing it on at the time because I can't remember what
his key take is right now. Um yeah, it's fine. I I was just I
was more just joking on the uh the whole Yeah, but mind [__]
lady mindset. I
He did like an eight minute fast facts thing and unfortunately
it's kind of like when I looked at his stuff for the Destiny
thing and he like totally misunderstood what sexual cyber Yeah.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. And he That was a bad one. That was a bad one.
And I can name that off the top of my head. So I'm not even arguing
you should take his advice. Was so I'm not even arguing you should
take his advice. I really am not. Uh, but I'm just saying that
I just one streamer saying it is not enough. Yeah, just one piece
of Yeah, exactly. Okay. Yeah, someone in my chat, so you're asking
something. Oh, you had a moment. So, I just thought I'd jump
in. Anyway, back in there. What are you Hold on. What are you
doing right now? I'm just playing Spider-Man right now. Boring.
Okay, cool. Talk to you later. Bye. All right. Catch you. All
right. Well, we made it through his fast facts video and there's
uh it wasn't fast or facty. So, damn.
Damn. Damn. Damn.
Okay.
Yeah. So, here's an art. Here's the article chat GBT gave me.
And I believe it says that they were introduced as a part of
uh copyright act of 1976 offer plaintiffs a number of different
potential remedies. A plaintiff may want to stop the defendant
from pursuing or continuing conduct harmful to the plaintiff's
interests. An injunction provides relief to such plaintiff. Perhaps
a plaintiff wants to ensure that the infringing materials are
not circulated to the public. The act allows a court to issue
empalments on the plaintiff's behalf. But most of the time, copyright
owners seek awards of damages as their remedy. US copyright laws
traditionally recognize two different types of damages uh damage
awards. Damages awards. On the one hand, copyright owners may
obtain an award of actual damages and profits. On the other hand,
a plaintiff may receive statutory damages rather than inquiring
into the harm that a copyright owner suffered as a result of
the defendants defendants's infringement. Statutory damages suggest
a broad range of potential awards and leave it for the judge
to decide what award seems fair. One problem with the current
state of the law is that the act gives courts too much discretion
and too little guidance to ensure that the awards of statutory
damages are fair and uniform. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That didn't really tell me all
I needed to know. Dude, is Kickhat right now? Why is Kick okay?
Are you guys good? I can't tell if those are going through or
not. Hello. Hello. Oh no, my kick chat's What the hell? Oh, I'm
in the I'm in the wrong version of Kickhat, aren't I? I need
to do the kick pop out thing. I think I have to do this. Yeah,
the one of the kick chat widgets that I used to use is really
I couldn't see you guys. I couldn't see you guys at all. You
were all typing. I couldn't see it. I was using the wrong I they
like didn't update one of their old URLs to the chat widget and
it goes to like some old component they don't upload any or they
don't update anymore. So, it just didn't work at all. Just wasn't
working. It was okay. We're back to Asminold
just finished talking about the the Mudahar stuff. Now he's going
to go over talk about lolly mindset. Like that one lawyer legal
mindset. I don't hate this guy. [__] Comment on this.
Yeah, this is this is legal mindset commenting on this. Lonesome
uh poet says, "Just got here wondering uh if what Ethan did is
considered entrapment."
Sorry. And once again, I want to explain this stuff. I'm not
I'm just laughing in general. So, and that's not a thing. Uh
you're you're probably thinking about like police entrament or
something else different. This is not criminal. This is copyright
infringement. So no, there's there's no such thing in the law
of entra. It's not even real. It's enforcing your right. And
I use it I use the example once again of the house, right? So
it's like putting an alarm on your house. Is that trapping the
burglar? No. You're lonesome. Uh oh god. Well, now get owned.
Yes. It's the dumbest thing I've heard today. No, it's not. Like
we had to watch a clip of her. That's definitely not the dumbest
thing. And so anyway, uh yeah, I I I don't understand how this
is is possible at all.
And it's amazing that this is I don't even know what to say.
It's a precaution. Yeah, I guess so. This is insane. The guy
isn't a real warrior. He has no idea what he's talking about.
Ethan's about to be sued for all his money for entrapping unknowing
victims. Okay. Okay. I just checked. I think you're you're memeing.
Okay. Okay. I was really worried for a second. No, it's okay.
It's all right. So, he's just joking around. He's just around.
It's all right. I I saw that and I was like, "Oh my god, there's
no way this is real, right? It actually isn't real." And so,
that's not it. And uh it's still a good defense. It's not enttrapment
for the legal definition, but it's bad faith. It it it's So,
it's bad faith for you to put out a YouTube video. I Okay, I
This is always a struggle, right? When you can't when you can't
at all recreate the other side's thinking like whatsoever when
you have no capability.
That's pretty rough, right? Oh, it's bad faith to put out a YouTube
video. No, it's maybe bad faith to like create this back and
forth dynamic to participate participate in this back and forth
dynamic to show a total willingness to participate back and forth
to react to things in a very similar way on your own stream to
react to things all over the place everywhere and totally seem
to operate within these rules. And then because they said, "Oh,
we want to take views away from you." Now it's like, "Oh, now
I have a copyright claim." I don't I don't know about that. And
I understand why Ethan I understand the maliciousness that that's
why Ethan wants to sue them, right? I don't think it's just the
maliciousness on that, though. But I understand like Ethan's
justification for picking targets. I get it. I do get it. Okay.
It's just a mess.
Where did these people come from? Where did where where are these?
We need, as I said, we need to do something about these people.
I don't know what it is, but there's something that needs to
happen. Let's see here if I can find the rest of this. And uh
where the to go? Women in Iran. What is women in Iran?
Can we do a drinking game? Would you do it? Every time somebody
says stop eating, it's bad faith for him to put out a video of
the intention of intentionally
with the intention of baiting them. Well, that wasn't the only
intention of the video.
I I think you you kind of can go to his state of mind what he
said, right? He was like literally I thought to myself, what
if I got to make a video that's so juicy that they would have
to react to it? Like it's lit in his thinking. Now, can he do
that literally? I don't know. I don't know. I don't know why
he said it. Like
that that wasn't the only intention of the video. And also like
for example, if somebody so like let's let's go ahead and just
let's apply this to another situation so we know how it is. If
you leave a PS5 in your car and somebody steals it out of your
car, is it entrament because you wanted somebody to steal it?
No, it's not. The guy that does that is still going to go to
jail for stealing because he stole a PS5 out of the car. This
is it. It it's I I like any other application of this logic is
just so immediately that it's un Hold on. Hold on. I need to
hear his other dad is still going to go to jail for stealing
because he stole a PS5 out of the car. That's Yeah. I mean, here's
the thing. There's there's actual tangible harm there, right?
That's the issue is I don't know how much harm Denims is responsible
for here. This is obviously stealing something, you're taking
something away from them, right? Like you're taking you're not
just taking something. You're like you're obtaining their thing.
It doesn't work. Asmin Gold's best example, okay, Asmin Gold's
best example right now is doing the thing that we all laughed
at when they put that in movie theaters. Okay. You wouldn't download
a car, would you? You wouldn't download a car. Asold is actually
saying right now, "Well, you wouldn't download a car, would you?"
You know what that old ad is right. It is right. You wouldn't
download a car, would you? It's I I like any other application
of this law. She's harmful for tens of thousands of viewers worth
of harm with stated intent. You're apprehensive for no reason.
Do you believe that all of those viewers would have watched Ethan's
thing live if Denims wasn't live? Is that what you believe? Hedgy
Hedgy. Okay. Cuz I think there's a real That doesn't matter.
What matters is some may have. Okay. So then why the did you
idiot say she's harmful for tens of thousands of viewers worth
of harm with stated intent?
What do you mean? How is she harm? How you just said some but
you did all of them. You said she's harmful for tens of thousands.
You just said that like concretely as a concrete statement. Most
could possibly have gone there. Why do you believe that? He hedgi.
This is literally like political culture war stuff. I feel like
almost everybody only consumes this through the lens of the creator
they started watching it through.
Because without pirating, they're forced to the source. Except
tons of people watch this pirating by your definition. Denims
did normal commentary
the whole time. A ton of other people did the same. Differentiate
denims from XQC
with record without recorded stated intent. Luckily for us, it's
a statutory crime and that stated intent means nothing. It doesn't
matter if you want to create a market replacement. It matters
whether or not you did. But you don't understand this. It's fine.
I probably shouldn't engage with one random who has no idea what
they're talking about. A sad sad stuff so immediately that it's
unfathomable that anybody could even believe it. The difference
video, it doesn't matter whether he said it on video. That's
not the point. You just had a lawyer explain it or somebody with
a legal background that Oh. Oh, fantastic. This hedgi hedgy guy
just said that stated intent means everything when she's transformed
nothing. That's the crux. There's too much that she did wrong.
Wait, is your argument Hedgi Hedgy that she transformed nothing?
That's your argument?
You understand that she transformed far more than most people,
right? That she had a totally normal by basically everybody's
standard react to that. Tons of commentary
or did you just believe Ethan? Do you believe Ethan when he said
she chair reacted to it where she said nothing substantial? He's
moving the goalposts. Okay, Hedgy Hedgy, you are banned. Join
the Discord, discord.gg/jdlk GG/JDLK if you want to be unbanned
and come and argue your points in the VC. Okay, good luck. Explain
it to you. I don't know. Are you going to tell them that they're
wrong and actually it's entrapment because he wanted them to
watch the YouTube video so he could sue them? Like what do you
really think that's going to work in an actual court? This probably
wouldn't even work in third grade. It's unbelievable. Trump made
a post. Let me see this here and then I was going to look at
the uh the other one. Okay. Only time will tell. Oh god. He he's
literally says, "I hate green tax credits." Oh my god. Start
with this idea about the two weeks. Uh there's been a lot of
discussion about it. How do you read it? Oh wow. So full full
screen doesn't even work on this website. Okay. I guess I mean
they're probably just talking about it. There's no reason really
to look at it. I have the answer on Google. It's literally for
only for law enforcement. These people are stupid. They're not.
The thing is that what you have to understand is that not only
are a lot of these people stupid, they are intentionally dishonest
and they're trying to lie to you. I don't think that you should
approach this topic with the premise that these other people
are just simply misinformed people that are acting in good faith.
Sorry, I you literally can't tell which side of this argument
he's on at all. Like it it literally just applies so perfectly.
It's so up. They're not. They are intentionally trying to lie
to you, misrepresent what's happening, and change it to make
it fit their worldview. They're maliciously ignorant, and they're
trying deliberately to misunderstand things. That's it. What
is this Iran thing? Iranian women can't post Tik Tok dances.
What? Iranian They can't post Tik Tok dances. What's funny? That's
a joke, right? You're saying that as a joke, right? Cuz
one, I don't think that's a metric for women's liberty. And two,
yeah, it is. Yeah, of course it is. Absolutely it is. If a woman
can't express herself by dancing, that that's absolutely a type
of expression that you can't do. Yeah, absolutely.
They can.
What are you talking about? What is What the I mean, they can't
right now because the the internet's shut off, but I think that's
what it is. They're facing for Iranian couple handed prison sentence
for dancing. Iranian woman arrested for dancing. Iran arrests
two young women for dancing. Is chase talk trying to do meta?
Assad is bad. I'm uh I'm not I sorry. I'm also sending messages
and stuff in the background trying to see what we're doing later.
I asked a couple people to hop on later tonight and I
haven't heard back. I It's weird. I just have not heard back
from people. It's too bad. In cemetery. Hard to say why. Was
it because it's a cemetery? Not long ago, two people in the cemetery
of martyrs in Tran disregarding the sacred site recorded a clip
with inappropriate clothing and movements that were outside of
the custom of Sharia. Woman arrested for singing in public without
hijab.
Whereabouts? That doesn't sound too good, guys. Uh-oh. So, he's
just lying. Uh, yeah. Yeah,
basically. Yeah, I guess so. I heard Iranian women aren't able
to eat processed love foods and consume Valium.
Bro, one thing I know about Persians is they can't stop dancing.
Okay, sorry. We We have been done with this for a quick minute,
for a hot second. Okay, going back to another clip. Asmin Gold
reacting to another ye clip here. Instantly align themselves
with oppressive organiz Oh no.
What? Oh, no. No, no, no. Yeah, I know. We'll make this. Why
won't she stop
a grander on a grander scale? If you check your bank account
and like Chase accidentally refunded you an extra 50 bucks, you
might look at that and be like like they were supposed to refund
you for some charge or something and then they accidentally gave
you another 50 bucks. And you see that and you're like, I didn't
see anything. Well, listen, they can correct it. They can find
it themselves. They can correct it. I don't really care that
much. All right. Um
I don't I don't really care that much. If some old lady on the
street is like, "Hey, you know, do you have change for a $10
bill?" Nobody carries cash around, but like, "Do you have change
for a $10 bill? I just need to pay the meter." And she hands
you a $50 bill instead of a $10 bill. Have you guys ever noticed
that all of the people that are arguing in favor of this type
of logic always are on the beneficial end of it? Has that ever
seemed like a coinc? That's Oh my god. Is that Is that dangerously
close to an actually like poignant statement from Asminold? That
is true that I don't think Denims or Hassan would ever say this
if they were the person being taken from. I really don't. Now
Hassan,
I am partial to the argument that Hassan does not Hassan only
doesn't care about copyright because he's lazy, right? I'm totally
partial to that argument. I I think if these people were being
substantially taken from in some way, even if they were quite
well off, I think they would be very against whatever that behavior
was. Absolutely. That all the people that argue about these things
that are okay, why is it always that they just happen to be on
the beneficial end?
Yeah, I totally think that's the case. Obviously, that's the
case. Luckily for us, only Hassan Hassan's the only person that
she could really take from and make like the same argument with,
not like Caseyron or any of the others. So, it's like not that
big a deal. Uh, one second. I want to pull up I forgot and I
didn't pull this up earlier. I did I did quote it. Hold on. Let
me find this tweet. The Contra points tweet. Contra points.
I I realize that I'm not take I'm not taking this in the way
it was meant. Okay, but new left tube seems pretty great. Real
recognize real. I think this is Contra Points admitting that
H is the future of the of Red Tube. Okay, he is the future. He
is the king. I'm the king of tankies. I mean, there ain't nobody
else. Ain't nobody else is stepping up to this. It's just me.
Everybody else is an apologist. You see Hakee and all these other
people, they're just trying to make it compatible. They're just
they're doing apologia. I don't do apologia.
I don't do apologia. I am a tanky in my bones. I'm a tanky in
my soul. I'm a tanky. I am a solinist.
It is what I am. I you know why they call me a fascist or whatever?
Because I'm a Stalinist before anything. I don't care about leftism
and liberalism and woke. I don't give a about any of his are
getting pretty big. That's what Spartan curls do for you, bro.
This guy is massive. This guy does chest day, chest day, chest
day, and chest day. That guy, this guy's back. There's nothing
there. Okay, it's just traps and then all chest muscles. Okay,
that's it. That's it. That shove it up your goddamn ass. Shove
the gender theory up your goddamn ass. Shove your fake ass postcolonial
defending the FBI studies up your ass. Shove all that [__]
up your He's short. Yeah, he is ask. I don't give a about your
Judith Butler goddamn Angela Davis. Shove it up your all your
goddamn ass. I am a Stalinist. I'm a I'm a real one. I am a real
Marxist Leninist Stalinist before anything. Wow,
this guy is so cool. S is working with Ethan, so no one will
critique his stuff either. Squash the commentary that hates that
he hates too. Um, conspiracy theory. Maybe. I don't know. I don't
know. Possibly. Sorry, when I say maybe, possibly, I mean obviously
not, but I just don't have the energy to explain why I don't
think that. Obviously not. Obviously not. Sorry, I'm uh I'm like
fading fast.
No, I don't want to go back and listen to Denim say this again.
Times are so tough right now, but you know, got to pay the meter
and you keep the 50. See how one of those feels morally worse?
One of those feels like you're stealing from someone who it is
morally worse, but you also shouldn't get used to stealing from
people. Stealing is just bad. Does need it, but you're stealing
from What do you want me to say? It's a good thing the way that
you feel about something isn't the way the law is. Well, I feel
differently about this, so it's okay when I do it. one of those
feels worse. We're not talking about legality. It's theft regardless.
We're talking about uh what is morally worse. It's theft regardless.
It's theft. It's theft regardless. Yes, it is. And um also, if
somebody gives you money, that's very it it it's this isn't even
really theft. It's just a mistake. It's a It's a mistake in a
transaction. What that you're allowing to happen. Like, this
isn't really theft in the same way. It's uh unethical maybe,
but I wouldn't even really call it theft. It's something else.
Uh it's just unethical bad behavior. Yeah, it's that simple.
And uh these simps elevate the dumbest people. Yes, moral relativism
is the worst moral theory out there. Well, the only people and
and you guys have to understand this. And once you put this piece
together, the rest of the puzzle makes sense. Every time that
there's a person advocating for something like this, they're
always advocating for them to be able to keep the extra $50.
That's the difference.
Every time that somebody wants to do this, it's always them keeping
the $50, and it's never somebody keeping their $50. This is again,
remember what I said before about how most people's worldviews
and most people's philosophies are completely self-referential
and they actually have no basis in principle, morality, ethics,
or any sort of guiding moral northstar.
Well, this is a perfect example of it. You can tell she doesn't
have a lawyer. Oh jeez, man. And uh if you know it was done in
error, it's still theft. Really? I didn't know that. Uh yeah,
I don't know. What's up, Nacho Mama?
Behavior no matter what it costs. Yes. Just I I don't know why.
Why can't you just steal something and say I'm a demon? Um why
do you have to Why do you have to be Robin Hood? Just be a demon.
Like that's okay. Like there's plenty of people that steal stuff
out of the store. Why do you steal this? Because it's cheap.
It it like I could pay $100 for this or I could get it for free
by putting it in my pocket and running away. Obviously I'm going
to put it in my pocket and run away. Like why do you why do you
need to do this? Like I don't understand that at all. Uh did
you lose the moral high ground point? Okay. I Okay. Yeah. All
right. Uh I have to run really quickly. I am unfortunately sending
all of you back to Quean. Okay. Is Queman online? He is online.
You're all going to watch Queen play Spider-Man. I will be back
tonight. I will be back tonight. Okay. It might be It might be
for the call. I'll be back. I'm going to walk away for a little bit.
Okay. I love you guys. I love you guys. I'm sending you over
to Quean for a little bit. Okay, I'll be back. Okay, love you
guys. We'll talk to you later. Bye.